I'd be like oh my God they're in my head
they they know they know that was the
song and so they put that song on the
radio and it's all everything revolves
around me because in the in The Truman
Show in the film like the cameras are
obviously all around and I'd be like you
know looking around my room and I'd be
like well that's that's the camera like
my light bulb in my my ceiling light
that's the camera and uh and so and on
The Truman Show the film everyone loved
Jim Carrey's character right everyone
loved him and so I want that I want that
[Music]
thank you
okay so Johnny obviously we've met
before if you want to give a brief
introduction to yourself and who you are
yeah sure so I'm Johnny and I am 35 I
had to think about that and yeah um
I've been working in mental health for
uh like just over a decades
basically because of my own lived the
experience of having mental health
issues
um my big my big focus is you know
getting to people when they're young
um because I just think if I'd have had
like the right education and
tools and support yeah things could have
been different for me so
yeah that's sort of what I want to do
now is help the Next Generation great
it's a great introduction so now let's
go back into your lived experience yeah
first of all would you mind telling me
what your diagnosis is yeah sure so um
when I was 20 I got a diagnosis of
schizoaffective disorder
and that's uh I mean I'd never heard of
that but anyway basically it's a sort of
combination of schizophrenia and well
schizophrenia and bipolar
but for me
I think it was more it is more
schizophrenia and depression I don't
well maybe a couple of times I haven't
really had the proper highs with bipolar
that some people get it's more the lows
like the real real lows so um basically
it's yeah it's schizoaffective it's
schizophrenia and a mood disorder
together got you and I think probably
everybody watching or listening will
have heard of schizophrenia yeah just
gets to effective disorder is I mean I
hadn't heard of it before I met you uh
is it a common diagnosis or is it
slightly more rare in that kind of world
iron is becoming more common so it's an
effective disorder the diagnosis with
schizophrenia uh schizophrenia affects
100 people
um
schizoaffective disorder is
um to be honest I don't know the actual
figures I should do shouldn't they one
in a hundred seems quite High to me do
you think so
yeah for what I would consider to seem
like quite a serious condition is it
because it's kind of a spectrum of how
much it impacts on your life or do you
think that once you've got diagnosed
with that it means it is having quite a
serious impact it's really interesting
with
like schizophrenia uh or psychotic like
illnesses like I think a lot of people
think you just you can't recover you
never recover I thought that when I got
my diagnosis but um it's like I think
it's around sort of 25 that actually
have one episode and then recover which
is amazing it is amazing I think more
people need to know that but you know on
the other hand that means that there's
like 75 that have to live with it you
know that don't recover from an episode
that have to carry on
uh yeah living and sort of managing with
it and I think for yourself if you don't
mind me saying and tell me if you don't
believe it's true but you are someone
who it's had quite a severe effect on
throughout your life so far so
what I'd really love to do now is just
get into that sort of go back to the
beginning of you and you know if you can
talk me through your childhood and your
first sort of experiences of this is it
called the disorder is that the right
way to describe it yeah I mean people
label it as a disorder but I hate that
term okay because it's like sorry no no
no no no I'm not criticizing you
I mean this this could be a whole other
thing like the language around sort of
diagnosis like I hate
I hate it what's a better way to say it
then just not disorder okay um because
this is something it sounds like what's
that condition
yeah I guess so I I've yeah I've got a
funny thing around
um
labels
um but completely understandably because
presumably you've had them sort of given
to you all through your life yeah so and
often with labels especially with
diagnosis it's not ones that we're
choosing to call ourselves it's not like
becoming something and saying I'm this
now it's someone else is saying you're
this so that's completely understandable
how do you describe yourself like when
you're talking about it do you say my
situation or condition or what do you
what do you use someone gave me some
really good advice when I was in my
mid-20s
um because you know I went to like a lot
of support groups and I would I would
talk about my diagnosis as me so like
you know I'm schizophrenic I'm
depressive and and someone said to me
why'd you do that because you know you'd
never say like I'm cancer I'm cancerous
you'd never say that you say I have I
have cancer I'm living with cancer but
when it comes to mental illness we often
say yeah I'm depressed or I'm yeah I'm
schizophrenic um do you know what I mean
and that that shifted things for me
because I was like yeah I hold it on
more than my mental illness I have this
thing but I'm more I'm more than it yeah
so let's go back to you in your
childhood and when you first realized
something was different yeah sure well I
mean
um
pretty early on I'd say I realized that
it didn't well I realized it didn't fit
in but I'd say things got really really
difficult when I was like I don't know I
can't remember the exact like age three
four oh very young though still yeah I
was young yeah I started to experience
what we call night terrors
um
I didn't obviously know what that was
back then but basically yeah things
would come to life for me absolutely at
night like I'd be in bed and um in the
80s there was an animated version of The
BFG role that was The BFG yeah and if
you remember
scared it scared the life out of me and
anyway I watched it and then I started
to see what I thought was The BFG at
night like coming to my window and
there's that there's that scene at the
beginning of the film The bft where he's
The BFG has got his hooded open and he
goes through the town to people's kids
windows and I was like
yeah I thought I heard him at my window
and like I saw figures particularly
around my bed
um anyway basically I stopped being able
to sleep properly
um because you're having these Vivid and
waking up from these vivid dreams well
no I was just lying wait I wouldn't go
to sleep I was basically annoying it I
was scared I was I remember feeling like
really scared I wouldn't sleep and
obviously my parents
didn't understand what was going on
basically I ended up I wouldn't sleep in
my own bed I would only sleep in their
bed
um and it started off one night and then
it just every night every night I guess
that must be hard as well because
you know I'm listening to that I've got
a um data who's almost four she has
night terrors she tells me she's seen
things she tells me she's seen things in
her room but like as a parent all kids
constantly say stuff like that so it
must be very hard for your parents to
differentiate you know to pick up on
something like that at that age because
I guess most kids are sort of saying you
know my my daughter will come back from
school and from preschool and say to me
oh they brought a line in today it's
obviously not true you never know well
yeah but you know she'll tell me stories
that are clearly untrue but I suppose
for your parents it must have been quite
hard at that point to go oh there's
something else going on yeah but you
know this was
this is the eight well 18 1989 1990
mental health was like not not talked
about that so particularly again coming
from a Jewish like conservative home
like it was not talked about so there
were lots of behaviors that I was
exhibiting that were
um
you know like
yeah I um like I'd interact with my toys
but
um
I'd interact with other people with my
toys
um and they'd all have characters and
they would do things that um I'm not
proud of like
um
I like like I'm my my one of my best
friends who I'm still actually uh the
very good friends with today I don't
know how he forgave me but basically one
day he he got his room redone and I'm
over with my toys and they all had names
they all had characters and these
toys started to like
pull bleach like all over his new room
it's really embarrassing and even
published on him and this was happening
in real life it was in real life but
you've got the bleach and you were
pouring well yeah but for me it was it
was the toys it wasn't me doing it and
for him actually blessed him he was like
oh my God stop your toys from doing this
um but um
I know yeah there were other behaviors
as well where do you got the bleach from
at that age well yeah bleach under his
sink in in his room
it's it's not great is it
um
but other things I would
um
I'd break a lot of stuff around the
house
um in my parents house like
I don't know I remember like just
randomly my mum got a new nice pair of
like candlesticks like really nice ones
and I just
and broke them with my toys though I'd
always blame them on my toys you know
all my toys had yeah these personalities
they had relationships I did lots of
like like when I look back like all the
trees in my garden had names and
characters and relationships and all the
even like cars like on the way to school
like they'd all have
I don't know I'd like role play sure I
was talking to each other and but when
so with the toys when you remember that
time do you remember it as you making
the toys doing it or do you remember it
as in the toys were doing it themselves
and you were just kind of present no I
believe that these this is a thing I
believe that everything was real like
the the night terrors with the BFG the
toys doing these things the
trees the trees in my garden that the
cars that
um you know all talking to each other it
was all in my head it was real because
as you say with your daughter like you
know at that age you just think you just
take it for what it is right you don't
question anything you're just like yeah
this is happening you know if this mug
comes to life then it comes to life and
starts moving and you know it just you
just take it for it you don't question
so even though it was you physically
moving the things in your head it wasn't
you it was them doing it and you were
kind of present yeah I believed I was
like an angel like good as gold right
there wasn't
um and yeah all these things that
like it's weird like when I look back
like I had no
when I went over to my friend's house
and I messed up his brand new room and
pulled bleach on him I was like um and
you know my mum obviously got called to
come and pick me up and I was like but
it wasn't me you know it wasn't me
um
it wasn't my fault I didn't have any I
didn't have any regret it makes me feel
like like
talking about it makes me feel really
uneasy but I didn't have any like I was
like it's the toys so it's not me so was
there a confusion about why you'd get in
trouble for things like that yeah and
I'd really lash out
really really lash out a bit you know
yeah I because I suppose to you it was
like someone saying to me
if my brother had done something it
would be someone like someone saying you
did that I may say no my brother did it
yeah and they just wouldn't believe me
which must have felt incredibly sort of
frustrating and confusing yeah yeah I
did
I did look I I lashed out more and more
and became more and more destructive I
yeah I'd get I'd get punished but again
I
I didn't feel any
regret or I was just angry at yeah being
punished because
I think a lot of it when I look back
actually is fear I was scared I was
scared of particularly like the things
that would happen at night you know with
like The Big Friendly Giant big friendly
giant The BFG I was I was scared I was
really scared and like the figures in my
room and the noises and
um I was scared and I couldn't probably
communicate that yeah I mean it must
have been terrifying if you thought I'm
gonna go in my room and all these
figures are going to appear and Surround
my bed and come in the window and stuff
like that it would have been a horrible
thing to know was going to happen every
single night yeah and so by this point
my mum and dad would take me to the
doctors right so had they sort of
realized that something was different to
the other children so was that a mental
health specialist that you've been going
to see at that age well initially I just
they took me to the doctor and then
eventually the doctor was like you know
after a few times
there's this letter that I have in my
records which is quite um
it's it's from my doctor to my what
became my psychologist psychiatrist
whatever I think psychologist anyway
basically being like this family really
desperate now you need to see this young
boy
he's violent and destructive and he's
not sleeping and he's doing this and
he's doing that so
um so yeah I think my parents lose it
that was a big thing for them because
um
again for a young a young really young
person to go and see her
you know Mental Health Specialists quite
taboo yeah you know yeah I think even
now decades ago yeah but even now I
think for like kids like we I think
we've got more of an understanding of
mental than adults but for kids
especially young kids like there's still
like a lot of fear you know oh my gosh
my my child at that age might there
might be something going on but like a
lot of fear a lot of so again like yeah
I did eventually see this psychologist
but again even with that there was a lot
of like
you know we don't really want to tell
like extended family
you know our little boys seeing this
psychologist this mental specialist do
you remember feeling embarrassed about
that at that age I didn't feel
embarrassed I remember feeling um
no not embarrassed I remember feeling a
bit confused like I was going to this
Hospital big hospital called Norfolk
Park in Heritage Hospital so I remember
being like
you know as a kid like they'd take me
there and
you know I had some understanding of
like what hospitals were so I was like
why am I going to this hospital and why
am I seeing this woman
every week and
um so it was quite frequent every week
yeah yeah yeah because so they decided
once you started were they like there is
something going on yeah yeah for sure
um
I mean I again I was really young so I
don't remember like all the like
interactions
with this I remember she was an old lady
and I was a little bit scared of her
um look somehow we managed to
kind of work through stuff
um in in those appointments in that time
um
and I think the big thing for me was the
night terrors in the Sleep So eventually
again it took some time but eventually
she managed to get me out of my parents
bear back into my own bed I had to sleep
with all the lights on but you know that
just seemed like progressed yeah that
was progress actually and not just for
me for my parents because it was you
know it wasn't easy for them hiring well
yeah having me like in the in the middle
of the
bed at home all every night and like
kicking them and
yeah it wasn't easy so I think yeah that
felt like progress for sure and so we'd
made you made a bit of progress there
and you've kind of got to the point
where you could move back into your own
bed and presumably at that point people
thought oh this is working and things
are getting better yeah so how did it
progress from there yeah I always I just
all the way through primary school I
felt
different and a bit lonely
a bit weird
um like so I would spend
I always spent my lunch breaks like on
my own in the library and I'd read the
same books and so I was obsessed with um
uh the tutors the Tudor period I was
obsessed with Queen Elizabeth at first
for some reason I don't know why so
every lunch time I'd go to the library
and just read the same book
um
but the thing
was that that school and most schools
have really just care about the academic
grades and academically I was doing
quite well actually
so everyone was like yeah Johnny's
you know he's very quiet he doesn't talk
much but he's doing really well in his
exams and that's all we let's see if
it's going well it's going well because
academic yeah and in the background
while this was happening do you think
that the situation with your mental
health was kind of just running a kind
of stable kind of level or did were you
feeling Peaks and troughs like were the
points you'd feel like you had more
imaginary things happening or was it
just all pretty much much of a muchness
you know I'd say that my sort of
like when I was seven eight nine ten I
was quite quite stable actually and this
is where
so religion actually played a big part
as I started to because basically you
know it
I had to go to Sunday school
um
and you know learn about
cause and you know the Bible and
and that was that really had a
I don't know that really had a sort of
impact on me and then so you know it was
a a good impact no not really well I
thought it was a good impact at the time
but looking back I was scared like again
I
I was scared I was quite fearful of the
things they were telling me about
God and you know
um sinning and and so in terms of the
gender thing I remember I ended up my
secondary school was a Jewish secondary
school and so
you know then it was just constant in
terms of and and you know they they were
against things like homosexuality and
they didn't shy away from that
and you know particularly when I you
know as you move into your secondary
school teenagers things do start to come
up right in terms of like sexual
um stuff is that when you started to
feel that way
that you've started to feel that you
might be attracted to I I knew well I
knew I I sent something I think I was
like around I feel like I was around 10
right when I remember I've got this
this recollection of basically sitting
in a restaurant and I I remember like
there was this waiter male waiter and
and
he was taking our order and I was like
I feel something here like I feel like
some sort of like there's an attraction
here and then I was like oh my gosh but
I'm Jewish and remember all those things
I was taught about about
homosexuality being a sin like oh my
gosh this isn't happening bury this bury
this down like this whole it was a
horrible sense of like guilt and
um yeah guilt and shame and I was like
even as a sort of yeah I think I was 10
even as like a 10 year old I was like
this this has to like
end now like Johnny like you just have
to like stop this like and
I think that's quite sort of messy for
for a young person's mind right
definitely you've gone through this
process you've kind of been going
through the
teenage Hood where you're working things
out yeah you've got sounds like you've
got a lot going on because you've got
this thing brewing in the background
con um the the the diagnosis well what
would soon become a diagnosis you've got
the sexuality which you might not be
completely comfortable yet with yet and
you've also got the religious thing
where I guess you probably felt the
pressure towards your family to you know
perform in a certain way and be a
certain thing
um
I've heard you talk previously about
something called The Truman delusion
yeah was that was it University that
started out for you or slightly before
no it's before it was before it was
before do you mind explaining what that
is yeah so so
that's um yeah I went to the cinema I
was 10. so it was Truman show with Jim
Carrey had just come out it was big I
remember it was big everyone was talking
about it
and I went with my best friend and we
saw it
and that film had such an impact on me
um
and and my best friend
and when we came out the cinema my best
friend said to me
wow like you never know but like you
could be on your own version of
the treatments are
and um then it was just like oh my God
like
yeah
I could be and and this like it's quite
difficult for me to say but I kind of
want to be I I felt completely like
um
you know when especially starting
secondary school I said I didn't fit in
I felt like a complete loner complete
Outsider and so the thought of me being
on this TV show and like people watching
me and people liking me I was like okay
okay yeah maybe and then it's amazing
how you can convince yourself like you
know things are happening that aren't
happening
so it didn't help but my best friend
would because he knew that
it was there in my head and and he would
do things
I'm sure he didn't mean to like you know
do these things people do things like um
you know in The Truman Show in the film
you know they're all like yes hold
things up to the camera like sponsorship
yeah product placement and
um like oh this cup of coffee is like is
the best coffee I've ever had and like
um my best friend would do that you know
it'd be like oh this um
and so part of me was like
you know is this
real you know is he is you know what is
this so for him he's doing it as a kind
of joke to tease you a little yeah but
not realizing that for you you'll start
looking at that and going oh my God it's
proof yeah oh God like every every sign
that I could
like grab to make me believe that I was
in this show I would so like you know
like things like even things like which
this is quite far-fetched but like you
know you know sometimes I'd have a song
playing in my head
and then I'd get in the car and on the
way to school that song was the first
song that came on to the radio and so
um I'd be like oh my God they're in my
head they they know they know that was
the song and so they put that song on
the radio and it's all everything
revolves around me or you know
and this happened well sometimes happens
today
you know I'm
I'm thinking of someone in my head
someone under there like on the street
or in in back in school in the
playground there that that was the
person I was thinking of they're there
they're in my head they're like
everything is like because in the in The
Truman Show in the film like the cameras
are obviously all around and I'd be like
you know looking around my room and I'd
be like well that's that's a camera like
my light bulb in my my ceiling light
that's the camera and uh
and I I did I liked it at first I really
liked it because I was like
people are going to see me people are
gonna actually see me and and and yeah
like me that was the big thing I just
wanted to be liked and so and and on The
Truman Show the film everyone loved Jim
Carrey's character right everyone loved
him and so I want that I want that and
so yeah at first it was great but then
obviously
as I got older and needed more privacy I
was like I don't want these cameras here
anymore like well yeah that's what I'm
thinking because once you get to a
certain age if you're trying to do
private things or whatever it is
whatever's funny look from you there
whatever it might be you wouldn't want
members of the public or potentially
your parents or you know in your head
were your parents in honest yeah
everyone was there everyone was in on it
so they were all watching you yeah but
that was okay because
I know I keep saying this but the then
it's still an issue for me like this
needs to be like universally not just
even liked but loved like like Jim
Carrey on The Truman Show like I needed
this Universal
yeah love because ultimately I didn't
have it for myself so I needed everyone
else's validation and we're taking a
quick break from the episode now to talk
about one of the sponsors of this
episode Harry's you might have heard of
their products before our producer
Connor actually already uses them so
Connor tell me about your experience
with Harry's yeah I'm a big fan of the
Harry's Razer blades
um I've done about you guys but
sometimes when I close shaver I wet
shave I tend to get a shaving rash if I
don't use the right products but I find
that Harry's eradicates that it's a five
blade razor
um it comes in a variety of colors I've
got a nice bright orange color myself
lovely what are the other options of
color I believe there's a green like a
forest green and a blue and also a black
that would be what I went for if I close
shaved nice and what are the kind of
products do hurries do so actually I got
a bit of a kit when I signed up to
Harry's and it came with um the
Fireblade razor the the razor head
obviously
um the foaming shave gel which smells
lovely aloe vera and that's what I find
helps me protect my skin
and also what I find really handy is the
uh travel cover so if you're putting
your razor in a wash bag it stops it
getting other bits and pieces in there
and protects the blades themselves
fantastic well it's a five-star review
from you Connor I think it is yes if you
like the sound of that uh Connor
certainly seems happy with the product
then you can get started by heading to
harrys.com minutes you can get a free
trial set all your cover is 3.95 for
delivery and you'll get it sent straight
to your door and listeners of the show
will also get a free Hydrating Night
lotion too to pick that up it's
harrys.com minutes but but I suppose I
want to get on to now about the um you
know what what happened at University
that really led to
a big change in your life you're kind of
you know diagnosis and what happened
after that yeah I mean um
University uh I had some and again I had
some great times like really had some
great times
the great times are amazing but the
bad times but
awful
a university like everything was taken
to more extreme level So like um the
depression like
felt like even maybe because I didn't
have the comfort of home and my family
to again run to escape from everything
felt more extreme and so I started to I
don't know do things like self-harm and
misuse alcohol and
um that was yeah that
obviously that was a real both of those
things were because it wasn't just the
one-off thing I didn't just self-harm
once it was you know
yeah same with the alcohol like you know
it becomes a thing
and and what annoys me actually
is that I was going to my student doctor
I didn't want to tell anyone else I was
going to my student doctor and it just
wasn't taken seriously as as I hear all
the time from young people you know
their mental health is not taken
seriously it's like oh you're stressed
you've got University work no there
might be something else underlying going
on
you know so I just felt really um on my
own with it again like at University no
one ever talked about mental health I
know it's different now but no one like
people talks a lot about like safety in
your whole residence or your student
house or or or
um security like no one talked about
mental health so I I've literally felt I
was the only person that was going
through some sort of thing because
everyone else seemed happy all the time
everyone else seemed like they were just
living their best lives
so do you think to other people looking
at you they'd have thought that about
you too or do you think they would have
said oh he doesn't seem like a very
happy person no initially
people were like yeah Johnny's great but
then
um people started to I
particularly with self-harm
the self-harm that I was doing people's
side to notice oh it was obvious was it
yeah it was obvious come my like second
year and then into my third year it was
like and the drinking like it was like
and the amount of times people would be
like Johnny what's going on but I was so
good at like putting people off the
scent I was so good at like oh so they
would actually address you and ask about
it
yeah but they wouldn't
and I'm not I'm not criticizing them
because we didn't get taught about how
to talk about mental health but they
would ask me once and then they'd be
like okay so you're stressed fine I'll
leave it
and I'm not again it's just the way that
it was
um but yeah I was able to throw people
off the scent they were able to like
divert so yeah
um
but I in I can't remember what year it
was now first second year I started to
take antidepressants
[Music]
um
it didn't seem to really work my head
was just felt like it was just getting
more and more scrambled
um more and more
um again especially with things like the
drinking
um
and then I think
I think for me that it was going into my
third year that hit me over the edge
um
because that's when I started to really
um
think about homosexuality you know if
you this was University and like you
know students were getting up to all
sorts so I was like
why not me
so um
yeah in the first time of my
third year right
I
one night I I got with a guy
um
that a bit online
and uh
that
that experience
um sent me into a psychotic episode
um
essentially
because uh
I
well all the feelings in terms of the
religion came back like the guilt and
the shame I was like I remember leaving
the morning after
I was like oh my God like what have I
done what have I done like what have I
done what am I doing were you still a
religious person at this point
yeah yeah yeah
I I
put the feeling of sinning yeah yeah
yeah for sure for sure I quite I was
questioning my relationship with like my
faith and but it was still there the
like you know the feeling of having to
do everything right and and not sinning
was still there and so me
oh me being with this guy was like the
the
was like the worst for me in my head in
terms of you know
my faith what yeah it was it was
I just felt disgust like absolutely
disgusting myself for what I'd done and
that
yeah sent me
sent me over the edge yeah and how did
that manifest when you said you had a
psychotic episode it was actually if
three weeks before that
say I had my
I guess proper proper first psychotic
episode
sorry yeah I got my I've got my
timelines that's all right that's fine
but basically basically this was
November 2007.
um I
I had a car accident oh wow yeah but it
was only a minor one it's only a minor
car accident
um but basically someone reversed into
me and um
so it it triggered something in me
um it triggered this uh
this feeling of being completely out of
control like like I've never
obviously I'd had like you know real
serious depression and stuff but never
this feeling of being completely like
out of control not knowing what I'm
gonna do next like I felt
and uh
I started to drink
I don't know I don't know what else to
do I started to drink
and then um
I just got this
impulse like
I needed to get out my house
[Music]
and
uh
I go into a dual carriageway to go into
the middle of this dual carriageway and
then I started to um
to shout and scream these things I felt
like I was being possessed I felt like I
was yeah being possessed and um
I couldn't control the stuff that was
coming out my mouth
um it wasn't me it was like yeah I was
being
properly properly
possessed and
um obviously obviously people were like
stopping their cars I was in the middle
of this joke Irish way
but you know I think
to them they thought probably thought I
was on drugs or you know shouldn't be
approached
I was really yeah I was I was I was not
with it
yeah
but eventually I um
I kind of just cast and I knew at that
point like I I was out of control I
needed help and so I actually I phoned
uh my housemate
I was like I don't know what's going on
but
I need to go to hospital
um
and so yeah she well two of them
actually came and picked me up to me
said NE
H that was the whole hike
uh it was just didn't it didn't work
very well it didn't go very well
um basically they were like can't really
help you
um we can send someone out to see you at
some point but
I was like I need help I remember I
really like I was at the point now I was
like okay I don't care I knew I know I
need help I need help I need you to help
me and they're like
yeah we can we can send someone out and
I was like no I need help now that's
quite shocking to me to hear because
obviously it's not a situation I've been
it's not a situation I've been involved
in but the thought that someone could be
screaming on a dual carriageway a young
person uh and collapse and go 20 and
they say oh well there's not much we can
do you should go home like is it not
facilities for emergency
mental health it still goes on to that
is the amount of stories there of you
know yeah young people getting you know
there's young people people going to a e
in a really bad way
and they just told it you know can't do
anything for you now you know maybe in a
few days or next week or six months but
it yeah
again there's a lot of needs to change
okay so then you sort of return to your
life I guess we're told there wasn't
much could happen and then you met this
guy online and that and that did you say
that was a week later or two weeks no
it's three weeks later three weeks later
and that triggered a secondary
and how did how did the secondary
psychotic episode manifest well I'd say
that was more of a
that wasn't a full-blown light
not like the first one that was more of
a kind of like
I um yeah I I had the thing with the guy
the night before
and then the next morning I was like
and so I just I I got in my car I just
got in my car and I sped down
I sped down the um the m6 and he had one
back to my
and I was I felt completely out of
control I was crying the whole I don't
know how I did it like um
didn't I did it looking back I just I
don't know I just I was like I need to I
need to get back to my parents and so
and then when I got back to my parents I
just went straight to my bedroom and
um as everyone needs to leave me alone
everyone needs to leave me alone and um
my parents obviously knew straight away
that was like what what is what's what's
going
on he's not he's not right
eventually they managed to convince me
like you need to see someone ASAP and so
I did saw a doctor
um
look they prayed they paid for a private
doctor because they were that oh
really worried never see me like this
and I just
yeah I just I wrote down and I confessed
everything confessed I I just said
everything that had happened was going
on in my head and she was like you need
to go to hospital now
and that was it and then I ended up in
psychiatric hospital with sitting in
front of this psychiatrist
pouring everything out and then he was
like you've got
just get some effective disorder
yeah and that was that was that
when you heard that
it's quite a big things here isn't it
the implications for the rest of your
life and and the stuff like the Truman
delusion
realizing in that moment none of it had
been true it must have been a hard thing
to hear
yeah it was it was
horrendous
but
it was kind of like kind of like the
final nail in the coffin for me to be
like
sorry that's a bit it's not a very
concerned yeah for me to be like I'm
done this is this is because there was
not just this there was my sexuality as
well you know that obviously
I was like that this is oh God this is
it this is it I felt like yeah so yeah
sort of kind of death sentence and
I just then spent the next
month on this um
suicide War just sort of
I I don't know like just
just I think just getting to the point
of being like
I'm gonna do it now I'm gonna take my
life I just
yeah get into that moment of being like
oh I just I can't I I I literally cannot
do another second this is it I'm done so
it was that month was just I mean it was
it was hell it was hell but that was
what
yeah took me to that place of
done I'm done
I'm done yeah
and you got to a position where you did
actually make that attempt didn't you
which is okay do you want to talk about
how you got to the bridge
yeah yeah so I I
yeah I I
made the decision
um I was gonna run away
go to this bridge and so
um and once I'd made that decision I was
like right done done
final decision
no turning back um um and so yeah um
basically that was that was
that was the night of the 30th of
January 2008 so it's the morning of the
14th of January 2008
World Cup
at the pan in my head and did the usual
you know how to take my medication I had
to see my psychiatrist and I was like
and I was bullshitting I was like yeah
yeah I'm doing all right I'm getting
better yeah yeah yeah and then I
ran away I liked it seems surprising to
me that um you're on a suicide Ward and
you were able to just exit the building
yeah well they
they let me out for a cigarette because
I said I didn't smoke back then actually
but
um I was able to
well I'd seen other people do it you
know let you eat outside have a
cigarette but for me I was like as soon
as their backs turned and I'm quite good
quite a fast runner so I was like
as soon as their back was turned run run
run run and I ran I ran I was like
Forrest come like I ran I ran
yeah I ran to
the nearest station and you know I had
it all planned around the nearest
station and got the train and
um
yeah got to the the bridge and um walked
up
uh to the middle of it and
yeah uh
took myself over onto the onto the ledge
yeah and then I was there
and then what happened and then
um I mean I wasn't on the edge for very
long I mean look it I don't remember
that you know I was pretty I don't
remember like the time the seconds the
minutes but
I wasn't on that edge for very long when
this stranger this young guy came up and
stood next to me and just started to try
and talk to me
um
and um I didn't wanna I didn't want to
engage with him at first I just wanted
to leave me alone I told him that but
there was something about him that was
like he he wasn't gonna leave me alone
he was gonna stand there and and try and
help me and
I don't know
eventually I
I realized he wasn't going anywhere and
I guess yeah I started to
to you know engage with him and uh
it was really hard it wasn't easy but
yeah started to engage with him and
yeah it was tough for him I'm for me but
for him like you know I wasn't really
you know my answers were just one words
I didn't want to open up but there was
there was just something about him and
the way that you listened that made me
eventually like start to
you know talk a bit and I hadn't that's
the thing like I wasn't I wasn't
speaking in the hospital I found it too
difficult
um
and to be honest like the whole suicide
thing like you know
I I was
I was trying to I was trying to say when
I felt suicidal in the hospital and
they'd be like
right well yeah we will give you these
this medication now you told us that
we'll give you this medication now sleep
it off or calm yourself down and
whereas with this guy it wasn't like
that it was just like okay tell me talk
to me and I was like what you want to
hear about
you know what
so yeah
so was it the fact that he was genuinely
seemed like he was willing to listen is
that what made a difference yeah for
sure 100
willing to listen but also
willing to
enable to support and and
give me some positivity
that hospital was so Bleak and
the things that I was being told and
things that my family were being told
was just so Bleak you know
my psychiatrist was saying you know we
don't know what's going to happen to you
you are really unwell
obviously you know
you just want to be told you know it's
okay it's okay you can get through this
and finally this guy was like offering
that to me and I was like
okay well you know maybe maybe there's
something another way
look it took a long time for me to
yeah finally like he was obviously
trying to get me away from the edge and
get me off and it took time but
he stayed and he yeah he had so much
patience and empathy and
encouragement and
yeah managed to eventually get me off
and
away onto the
Paving and then did you after that did
you return to the hospital yeah yeah I
we were meant to go for a coffee but
um obviously someone called the police
of course right no it's obvious what was
going on so someone who plays and the
police
quickly
quickly charged in as soon as I got off
the edge and you know
um it got messy because I was
it just yeah I got a bit messy I was
scared I guess but had his had that
conversation stayed with you in the
sense that you weren't thinking as soon
as this is all over I'm gonna try again
it had given you a new Direction in a
way yeah for that day for sure and
actually yeah no it did it shifted
something slightly it did shift
something it did it was I mean it's
still really odd like you know
going back to the hospital for our
sections with the police I was a
sectioned not sticking back to the
hospital there was a lot of like my
psychiatrist was like
why what like my parents and everyone
was like
why didn't you say anything and I was
like
I
couldn't
um
so there was a lot like you know there
was so much that I had to like work
through
so it it took I mean it took a long time
but yeah that conversation it did it did
they did change something in me for sure
give me give me a little bit of hope I
think for sure 100 okay we're gonna take
a minute here guys to talk about one of
the sponsors of this episode which is
nordvpn Connor one of the producers of
the show already uses nordvpn so it
seemed to make sense to bring him in
tell us about it how do you find it
Connor really really useful yeah so for
me I use it mostly when I'm abroad and
I'm in the middle of a show that I'm
streaming on any sort of platform based
in the UK but obviously you have that
age-old problem when you're on holiday
with your family you want to watch the
latest episode but you can't because of
where your country is located then
you're on Holiday Inn uh nor VPN allows
you to change your location virtually
got you so you can catch up whilst
you're abroad and it stops any spoilers
from any of your friends on those groups
before you get home
um it's great for things like booking
hotels as well and booking flights
whilst you're in another country for
example it's great when you're traveling
I highly recommend it well Conor is
certainly a fan of nordvpn and if you'd
like to try it for yourself
extraordinary lives listeners can get an
exclusive nod VP deal by going to
nordvpn.com minutes you'll get a huge
discount off your nordvpn plan and four
additional months for free and it's
completely risk-free with nod's 30-day
money-back guarantee that's nordvpn.com
minutes
and I guess like you say there was a lot
of work to do after that and it probably
felt a little bit like did it well I
don't know I don't want to put words in
your mouth did it feel like your life
slightly went on pause you know you've
been in University and I guess now
everything else was
ultimately paused until you went through
this process
so where how long did that take
wow I mean it took it took years to be
honest I mean it's look it's still
has that still ongoing
um
yeah it's still ongoing because I have
relapses and so yeah it's still
still goes on but
I'm I think I'm in a different place
um a better place than I was back then
and
you know definitely for me
all those years of because there was so
much to figure out like in terms of
medication having to find the right sort
of
medication medications like the the
right Doses and stuff having the right
therapy and having it actually like you
know having an impact it all took years
and um
I said it still still goes on
um
but obviously I I think for me
yeah I look there was a lot of
there was a lot of denial at the
beginning a lot of
I don't want to deal with this
who my family and my friends it was none
of us were able to really talk properly
it was really hard for everyone
um in those first few years
um
not just with my mental but my sexuality
so
those first few years yeah there was
there's so much to work through and so
it yeah I'd say I say like all of my
early 20s were just
a bit of a write-off to be honest it
didn't work I didn't
function properly
um I didn't deal with it properly
and it was hard because I saw like all
my all my friends you know getting jobs
and having relationships and I just felt
stuck
so yeah it was definitely not until my
mid-20s when I was like
I feel a bit more human again now
finally
and you say now that you still have
relapses you know is that does that
still include the you know voices or
imaginary things or is that something
that's more under control now
I mean when I have a relapse
when I have a relapse I usually have a
psychotic episode and for me that
usually
usually manifests in um
more The Truman thing the Truman
delusion comes back obviously I don't
just like suddenly switch into a
psychotic episode there's a build up
but when I do switch into a psychotic
episode it's yeah it scares me like
how I can like with the treatment to
losing it
it takes over me so like I remember one
psychotic episode that I had
um
a few years ago
and I
so actually I was with
um
Neil the guy from The Bridge because we
reunited and which was amazing and
really amazing as part of a documentary
yeah a part of documentary The Strange
on the bridge reunited and um yeah it
was amazing it was amazing
but then
you know I wasn't looking after myself
um
and I was becoming unwell and
anyway one
afternoon when we were in in Covent
Garden in London which is obviously
quite busy I just
something happens we were really late
for a meeting and I
I lost it I lost it in this
well in this building and I I went to
the floor and I screamed and I ran out
into Covent Garden and then I was like
like everyone's everyone's everyone's a
actor everyone's and even to Neil which
was really hard because you know
obviously
yeah that was really hard because
um
yeah you know it doesn't matter what
someone is saying to you you really
believe or I really believe like
Everyone's an actor and this is all a
film set and
what makes it
you know what made that episode really
hard was obviously
people stop and stare don't they and
that makes me even more like I remember
someone with a [ __ ] camera out of
phone and [ __ ] started filming me and
I was like
yeah I'm on The Truman Show you're
filming me
um
but it's horrible
you know the people that you love like
people that I love like you know I
obviously love Neil and my family and my
friends and I'm like you're all actors
and this is all a film set and
you know I'm sitting here talking to you
and I'm like
obviously I now I'm in a place where I
you know although I don't want to think
about it too hard but you know I think
this is all legit and I think this is
all
a non-drum and show experience but when
I'm in that psychotic moment it doesn't
matter I
literally it doesn't matter like I'm in
that headspace of like
this is this is this is
this is um
encompassing me and this is what's
really happening and you're all like
fake and you're all lying and
yes and it's horrible because you can't
I can't get out of that headspace like I
remember I was like in that episode
I was having to like I had to close my
ears and I had to say things and I had
to Pace in certain directions and
eventually I you know I got to the
hospital
do you know at that point you're having
a psychotic episode despite the fact
you're doing it or is it just everything
goes into the psychotic no no because
I'm right because I'm right like because
I honestly truly believe
everything is fake everything is very
this is all a film set this is all
everyone is an actor this is all these
are all cameras the whole of me believes
that it doesn't matter again what anyone
says I believe that I'm in that fully
and I don't trust anyone and um I saw
it's a horrible feeling because you know
I'm
I mean yeah it's it's unfathomable to me
basically
and it sounds it sounds unbelievably
difficult but what I want to speak about
a little bit now is what you do now
because you are an inspirational person
in the fact that you were dealt quite a
tough hand but you've got yourself to a
position where you are helping others
I'd like to hear a little bit about that
yeah I mean I try I think
um
I think it's difficult because
do you want a minute no it's fine
honestly
because it happens
you know
but
uh it happens a lot in terms of
relapsing
and every time I have a relapse
you know I say that I'm never gonna have
another one
because I can't go through it again
but
yeah it's hard it's just hard because um
I do end up having and you know I so I
had my last three laps um
after I did the filming obviously I'm
not blaming you after I did the filming
obviously yeah
the lockdown
I've had a relapse just a couple of
months later
and that that was horrible because it
was you know locked down and I was back
in hospital and it was all locked down
the Walls it was horrible
and I was like this is my last relapse
this has to be my last three laps
I saw that
really difficult existence because
you think that
just don't know when another relapse is
going to come and
you know the work that I do
great but you know obviously working in
mental health
it feels like the only thing I can do
because I know it so well
I wish it I wish it
stopped me from
falling back into relapses and the truth
is like you know
I don't look after myself as maybe I
maybe I shouldn't I could
[Music]
um
I guess I'm lucky because you know I
I
you know I have a lot of support
and especially working with a mental
health I have a lot of support you know
I have a lot of support
but when it comes to the actual
I think because it's
any relapse is difficult because it's
the psychotic element and that feeling
of
a feeling of being out of control is
just no one wants to be out of control
right no I think we're all very
conscious of the fact that it must be
very difficult
um no nobody has to talk about it I have
to talk
because I spent such a long time
not talking about it made me so ill and
yeah I still get ill but not I don't
because I talk about it now it's
different the illness
different it's a tight I mean it's tiny
bit easier because I talk and I'm honest
and so I just want other people I meet
so many people
um and so many families that have been
affected by like particularly
schizophrenia is schizoaffective
and unfortunately a lot of time
the outcomes aren't the same as me
um because it's such a hard
illness and there's such a lack of
understanding and support out there
you know everyone that I've met with
like schizophrenia is the most
creative intelligent amazing people but
they're rejected by Society you know
this is the the statistic that gets me a
lot is that only eight percent of people
with schizophrenia are in work
in the UK which is but when you talk to
people a lot of people schizophrenia not
everyone but a lot want to be in work
they want to be they want to have a
purpose but you meet so many people
given these this diagnosis and you meet
their families and they're just like
rejected and I felt that way like
through my early 20s I was like I'm not
a part of society anymore I'm
you know I'm not yeah I'm
I'm a reject now and I realize that I'm
it's all the way that I've done and I've
done quite a lot of work on myself
um I realized that I do have a purpose
and that there is a role for me in
society and I just want other people
who have schizophrenia psychosis to
realize that they are also
worthy and valuable and
um they have really made a part to play
in this Society look at all the people
like
um all the artists and the crazy people
the singers the musicians that had had
schizophrenia have schizophrenia so
talented and they just don't get the
help and support and the recognition and
and and and the encouragement that they
deserve so I just want to change things
for
um all right um Johnny I mean it's been
incredible sitting down with you again I
suppose the last thing that I want to
ask you is if there's anyone listening
to this or watching this now who
feel some kind of similarity to what
you're describing and might quite not
understand it what would you want to say
to them I think first you don't be
embarrassed like don't be embarrassed I
know that's easy for me to say because
of you know sort of overcome that
embarrassment but
there's nothing to be embarrassed or or
ashamed about you know it's
I've learned it's the brain it's the
it's just it's the brain you know it's
not
it's it's no different to like uh you
know another organ in the body like you
know I know lots of friends family that
have you know other health issues right
um maybe like like Crohn's disease for
example and you know they they talk
about it they're open about it they they
and and so should we if we have you know
things going on with our with our brains
there really is nothing to be
yeah embarrassed about like there's so
much out there now in terms of support
maybe that's um yeah maybe that's a
doctor maybe that's a clinician maybe
it's but actually groups like for me
going to groups uh do you know what I'll
never forget the first time I went to a
group and it was a group for people that
experienced schizophrenia
schizoaffective
and went into this room and sat down and
just
everyday people and they started opening
their mouths and things were coming out
their mouths and I was like oh my gosh I
I have these things in my head like I
can't believe this I'm not alone like
the best feeling in the world is when
you feel like you are
human again when you feel like you are
you know you're not alone when you feel
like there's other people going through
the same things as you it's the best
feeling in the world and so there are so
many other people out there going
through what you're going through and so
you know please like have a look and see
what's out there you know around you
near you I just I believe there's always
something out there for everyone so you
know
please don't give up it's a lovely
message and um you're a lovely person
and it's a pleasure to meet you again
and you remain inspiration to me and I
can see the crew nodding as well
um thank you so much for sharing your
story and wish you all the best and I
hope we do stay in touch thank you
thanks Johnny thanks man thank you
you know depend what you were Scavenging
for you know and um and so yeah that was
a bit unnerving because again you know
there's always a rabies threat and stuff
like that left out of James Bond didn't
they the rats in the rubbish didn't you
yeah yeah I wouldn't have been doing it
in my tuxedo for sure